[Music]
this time from an i am
oh i actually played this one before
goldstein
um french i am
it's kind of interesting
so he's repeating he's repeating what i
was doing with
uh bishop c4 let's
it's gonna be a theme match huh okay let
me see if
[Music]
i can try b5 and if i can do better here
than my opponent's opponents did there
not sure though
but no more of the rats and such
so it just takes i feel like this is
supposed to be
supposed to be okay for
for black slightly unnerving of course
that is playing so quickly
so what do i have here knight f4
doesn't look too bad queen f3 there is
oh we can go bishop c6 that's a mess
i was thinking of queen of three and
then i have e4
that's my big point
but yeah i think
i think he's missed knight h3 and then
queen b5
he's gonna attack two of his pieces
um yeah or it
attacks f uh
f1 as well as um
yeah okay so still not
it's not it's still not clear at all i'm
i'm finding out
since he now is threatening the rook on
98
if bishop b7 there's queen h4 check
picking up the knight in h3
so what should i do
rook b8 queen b7 is a move
yeah let me just cover appearance cannot
be too bad
so d meteor gh doesn't work because of
bishop b7 skewering
the queen but
yeah knight c3 is perfectly possible now
i don't have a way to
to keep the keep the knight so
i could just go like queen f5 exchange
queens and
then i'm probably not doing too badly
but i don't want to do that so i'm just
going queen d7
if he takes the knight i'm gonna brook
b4
uh threatening bishop b7 and i'm hoping
to have
decent compensation there i'm a couple
pawns down my king is in the center but
i do have
two bishops so i feel like
objectively this cannot be too
disastrous
for me and also practically speaking i
feel
i feel that i'm doing pretty well
if queen a8 pinning the bishop then i
think i'm going
bishop d6 threatening
um queen h3 which would be would be very
very unpleasant for him
yeah king g1 but i do feel as though
that is a bit slow
now that he has queen f3 i think i can
take an h3
yeah i think i can do that um there is
bishop h5
sorry bishop g5 but i think i can go
wish b7
that's what i was relying on
f6 bishop f6
take it i probably don't have a good
square for
yeah okay he's playing really well
it's very unclear at this point
if you go back to d8 i feel like the
king is a bit more active there than an
snf8
he does have to exchange queens now and
this
means that
i am doing i am doing pretty fine
uh although i had sort of underestimated
knight b5 now we can take an a7
[Music]
okay let's go f6
yeah i didn't see that he was
threatening rookie seven this is all
going south at the moment for me
okay now i'm gonna have to to play fast
and potentially fly him in order to win
the game
but i can do that
space three
we're okay two back yeah i'm not gonna
accept a draw of course
we're not in the charity business here
now i'll gain a couple of pounds back
and
should be winning the ending rick h4 is
going to win another pawn
next and that's going to be the end of
the game
for provided i don't like
which i shouldn't do since i have a lot
more time
yes oh don't stay away tim
let's make next okay
uh very very tough game right there
came down to the wire as three minute
games
often do